all right let's get to emails the Friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpackman.com sometimes we'll include
a tweet or a YouTube comment or whatever
today we're starting with a Facebook
message and it is a pretty ugly one this
one is from James James writes your
a very misinformed [ __ ] now your is
y-o-u-r it's almost a requirement if you
write trumpist hate mail that you use
the wrong your okay you're a very
misinformed [ __ ] I have never seen
Trump shocked about anything Democrats
have tried the Democrats are scared of
trump because they can't control him as
they control Biden that's because he
doesn't want the truth is their response
to a message saying by the way David
can't respond to you individually this
is a really common thing we see
for many of these Maga people
which is Democrats are scared of trump
the problem with dealing with Democrats
are scared of trump is of course you
know and I know it's not scared of trump
it's horrified at what a disaster he is
and the truth is
it is scary the things Trump would do if
allowed to do them they use the word
scared in a very different way they use
scared to mean intimidated by just
overwhelmed with Trump's masculinity and
intelligence and drive and all these
things that make absolutely no sense to
feel about Donald Trump no we're
horrified in the way that you're scared
of really serious illness or a fascist
dictator or you know whatever the case
may be
um but of course good luck explaining
that to them and why is it always the
wrong Yore can someone explain to me why
that is I would love to understand it
Michael wrote In
Michael wrote about coverage of the
Colorado shooting and said hey David
I've been a listener for a while but I'm
curious about why you haven't covered
the Colorado shooting I've listened to
both Monday and Tuesday shows following
the weekend shooting and I cannot recall
your coverage of this thanks Mike so
there's there's two things going on with
my coverage of shootings and I'm glad to
sort of change my perspective if it
makes sense to change it number one is
there are so many shootings in the
United States
and so many of them are mass shootings
and so many of them are happening in
ways that are motivated by the I certain
identity factors which is sort of what
we call hate crimes right targeting
lgbtq people or Jewish people or
whatever the case may be
that it's sometimes hard to find
something new to say about them and
I sometimes feel like I don't have
anything to say about these shootings
because they are so common that's one
thing
second thing is in particular when there
are some of the really big shootings
they get a lot of media attention
a lot of the early information is often
wrong
and with certain breaking stories
you still report on them early
because they are unique stories and
while of course every single one of the
victims of a mass shooting is unique we
don't go well there have been other
people killed in mass shooting so the
victims don't matter no that's not what
I'm saying but what I am saying
is that because this the circumstances
repeat themselves time and time again
uh I find it less useful to just report
what we know three hours in or whatever
the case may be so we ended up talking
about the shooting on Wednesday this
email came in about Monday Tuesday we
talked about the shooting on Wednesday
that's why I sometimes am deliberately
slower in reporting on some of these
mass shootings people want them reported
on more quickly I'm willing to do it I
just don't know how much I have to add
particularly when we don't yet have the
full story Michael wrote in about
evidence-based medicine and says David
great start to Monday's show explaining
the risks of cardiac complications from
vaccines compared to risks from covid
you explain things clearly calmly and
with a high level of expertise thanks
sadly the people who would most benefit
from your charitable sharing either
won't understand it or won't listen yes
that is often the case on another note
it is unfortunate you have to waste your
time answering Critics on your show but
on the other hand you do acknowledge
your critics and that is more than
Hannity Carlson Jones O'Reilly or the
others on the right will do keep up the
good work it really matters thank you
Michael no comment just presented
without comment very much appreciate
that message
Teresa wrote in with a request that I've
gotten from many people Teresa said hey
David can you give members access to
your soundboard pretty please best
Teresa oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad yeah you
all know the sound board so here's the
deal with the sound board I would love
to set up as a feature for our members
that's a great bonus feature an extra
feature
access to the sound board that I have
here for the show
I don't know how to achieve that from a
technical perspective
I guess we need some kind of a web-based
soundboard system
that is maybe password protected or
unlisted in some way so here's my
thought if anybody out there knows how I
can do what Teresa is asking which is
make access to my soundboard a premium
member feature if you can tell me how to
do it I will do it and I think that that
would be a really cool thing to be able
to offer Melissa wrote in about YouTube
and Melissa says we watch your program
every night in our home well thank you
Melissa Melissa adds I've blocked out
when you talk about subscribing to your
YouTube channel only because we don't
watch you on YouTube we watch your
program on Free Speech TV
I have since come to my senses and
subscribed thank you for all the work
you and your team do to keep us informed
Melissa from Wisconsin thank you Melissa
yeah listen
even if you watch on another platform if
you want to do us a very small and
completely free favor if you have any
kind of account
with Google YouTube Etc
subscribe to the channel it really helps
us we're working to 2 million
subscribers you go to youtube.com slash
the davidpackman show quick easy and
very important Justin wrote in about
this idea of executing drug dealers that
summon the Maga right including the
failed former president Donald Trump
have started fixating on Justin writes I
find it interesting Trump is saying all
convicted drug dealers should be
executed and not specifying what drugs
you need to be caught dealing or
trafficking in order to get executed is
he saying people convicted of dealing
cannabis should be executed serious
question I think he is saying that quite
frankly I think he is saying that
because he's not making any distinction
and I mean listen I guess we have to ask
him it's often very hard to know what it
is exactly that Trump is suggesting
but he doesn't seem to be making any
distinction
as far as which drugs the dealing of
should get you executed but the most
important thing is it's completely
hypocritical because remember that even
though Donald Trump is now saying drug
dealers are such a Scourge or Scourge as
he used to say during the covet era that
they should be killed
he also pardoned a bunch of drug dealers
on his way out of office so maybe not a
shock to some of you
that he's a bit of a hypocrite okay last
thing Dylan wrote to me a message called
on judgment
and tells me that in the following text
he will attempt to explain the principle
of non-judgment
and why he believes it to be a just
tenet on which to base our relations
with others he then sent pages and pages
of all sorts of biblical talk that is so
long-winded that I couldn't even fit it
on the screen
do not send me this stuff
it is not being read by anybody we have
a message on our website on the contact
page which says email in your message
will be read but me David I can't
necessarily read every email and I
certainly can't respond to them but
someone's going to read it
no one is reading this stuff
Dylan no one is reading pages and pages
of biblical mumbo jumbo about
non-judgment it's just not getting read
it's not relevant to the show please
please please just don't bother because
you're wasting your time and now you've
wasted my time and the audience's time
with me explaining
that it's not going to be dealt with
okay so please know more other emails
info davidpackman.com we've got a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com get instant access and of
course the coupon code 24 starts now is
available also the free white paper on
arguing politics and changing Minds is
available at davidpackman.com guide I
will update you next week
on the number of downloads but I am
quite ready to call it a success